sí
recuerdan a patrick del primer vídeo de
esta lección lo invité para que nos
hable un poco del uso de la cámara
puedes platicar nos un poco de cómo usan
la profundidad de campo al contar una
historia pulsamos la profundidad de
campo como parte de la historia en un
cortometraje en el que trabaje
y que se llama a su lado cuando el
director zasca me pidió que me encargará
de la dirección de fotografía quería que
el público sintiera como se desarrollaba
la historia de amor frente a sus ojos
así que la idea era usar una lente más
larga para que hubiera distancia entre
la cámara y el protagonista
es como cuando estás enamorado no solo
te concentras en la persona que tienes
enfrente y esa es la sensación que
queríamos transmitir
ah
además de otras decisiones que tomas
también podría decidir mover la cámara
durante una toma llegas a hacerlo para
contar la historia si el movimiento de
la cámara es muy importante en
intensamente el movimiento de la cámara
es una parte importante de la estructura
de la cámara respecto a cómo funciona el
mundo interior y el mundo exterior el
mundo interior es perfecto es
imaginativo así que todos los
movimientos de cámara son muy mecánicos
es a propósito cada vez que se mueven
puedes predecir adónde van todo es muy
formal por el contrario el mundo externo
es más orgánico depende del momento así
que como movemos la cámara es muy muy
importante usas el enfoque como una
cámara real para asegurar que se enfoque
en los elementos importantes llegas a
usar el enfoque para contar una historia
o la manera en que enfocas si de hecho
en intensamente usamos el enfoque para
tratar de incrementar la imperfección
del mundo real el mundo de reyli el
mundo de rallys
en un lugar real san francisco minnesota
queríamos que la cámara se sintiera
natural que se sintiera real y la
imperfección forma parte del mundo real
algo acerca del enfoque de pixar es que
todo es siempre tan perfecto porque
estamos dentro de una computadora así
que a propósito especialmente en los
actos 2 y 3 cuando el camarógrafo sigue
una acción a propósito desenfocados y
luego lo enfocamos forma parte de las
sutilezas que intentamos hacer para
llegar a la imperfección esperamos que
el público lo sienta pero que no sepa
decir cómo lo hicimos exactamente
gracias es fascinante gracias por venir
bueno pues gracias por invitarme ven